bonjour david rigoulet roze merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors on l'a dit un téhéran se réjouit
d'un résultat significatif après c'est
pour parler du week-end résultats
significatifs qu'est ce que ça veut dire
exactement
sears à suspens les lignes rouges qui
étaient en train d'être remise en cause
le rafale est grossi à signifie que
c'est un accord bilatéral technique sans
dimension politique parce que l'enjeu il
est sur le fond des négociations et les
considèrent à juste titre qu'il n'est
pas habilité à l'est à les mener il faut
rappeler que le la ligne rouge en
question était devenir effective le 23
23 février justement sur la restriction
des inspections de l'aiea
des inspections de l'aiea et la remise
en cause du protocole additionnel c'est
ça fait référence à une loi qui avaient
été votées par le majlis le parlement
iranien le 1er décembre dernier qui
était dit d'action stratégique pour la
levée des sanctions
on voit bien qu en arrière plan c'est
effectivement l'obsession terrain ce qui
est compréhensible par rapport à
situation économique c'est la levée des
sanctions et l'objectif c'était de ne
pas hypothéquer la reprise de
négociations donc on est dans la
subtilité personnes dont quand on écoute
la déclaration du ministre arrive c'est
à dire qu'il ya quand même une
restriction des inspections de l'ordre
d'un tiers les enregistrements ne seront
pas remis tant que les négociations ne
sont pas finalisés et en même temps ça
ne remet pas en cause la les engagements
de l'iran donc on voit bien que c'est
une ligne de crête qui est qui est
extrêmement ténus et qu'il s'agit de
maintenir la possibilité effectivement
de négociations avec washington qui a
accepté justement à l'invitation des
européens une réunion informelle pour ce
type de négociations vous parliez tout à
l'heure de cette loi iranienne censée
entrer en vigueur demain qui limiterait
justement l'accès des agents de la cia
en iran est ce que les discussions ce
week-end est ce que justement cet accord
peuvent remettre en cause cette loi non
comme l'a rappelé le ministre aux arrive
ça remet pas en cause la loi mais en
même temps il ya une dimension
suspensives dans les modalités
techniques c'est toute la subtilité de
la chose si je
et effectivement il ya une restriction
des inspections du watchdog donc là et
mais en même temps la u a un peut
continuer son activité minimale pour
pouvoir avoir une vue sur l'ensemble du
programme iranien
donc j'allais dire le la face et sauf
pour tout le monde d'une certaine
manière c'est ce qui comptait et c'est
ce qui permet de laisser la porte
ouverte pour pour la suite on le disait
aussi tout à l'heure les etats unis qui
ont avoué il ya quelques quelques jours
être favorable à un retour dans les
accords de vienne l'iran qui dit aussi
favorable à des discussions avec avec
washington cet accord trouvé récemment
et puis ces discussions du week-end
est-ce qu'on se dirige vers un avenir
assez positif une normalisation des
relations entre tout le monde
là ça va être la vraie question parce
qu'évidemment il ya une bonne volonté
évidente de la part des deux parties il
ya le souhait de renouer après l'impasse
stratégie de pression maximale de
l'ancien président donald trump donc ça
c'est clair
en revanche pour les attendus des uns et
les autres les choses se sont beaucoup
plus complexes parce que les iraniens
veulent par-dessus tout et manière
immédiate la levée totale des sanctions
ce qui est impossible du point de vue
américain
les américains de toute façon s'ils sont
prêts à réintégrer le gisti piot a donc
la corde 2015 c'est sous réserve d'un
certain nombre de conditions et
notamment de de négociations pour un
accord plus restrictif qu'il mettait en
2015 ce dont ne veut pas entendre parler
terrain donc là on va rentrer dans le
dur et c'est toute la complexité de la
situation
justement que peu changé l'arrivée de
joe biden à la maison blanche
dans ces accords justement il disait en
vouloir
vouloir potentiellement revenir dans les
accords de vienne vous parliez de
conditions quelles seraient ces
conditions en arrière plan c'est la
question du balistique
on y est et de la stabilité régionales
d'ailleurs ça a été évoqué de manière
plus ou moins explicite par le président
joe biden et son secrétaire son
secrétaire ce justement anthony blinken
blinken et donc c'est ça qui est en
arrière plan et la nouveauté par rapport
à la précédente administration c'est
qu'une convergence de vues qui semble se
dessiner entre américains et européens
justement sur l'enjeu que représente la
prolifération balistique et là on
retrouve des questions que qui
normalement ne sont des questions
périphériques à l'accord lui même et
c'est précisément ce qui va être en jeu
donc dans une redif yvelines une
renégociation potentiel est ce que le
retour potentiel des épées réunis dans
ces accords deviennent arrange quelque
part peut arranger quelque part l'iran
de toute façon l'iran son objectif
principal c'est la levée des sanctions
il ne menaçait de le dire et donc si on
le fait de s'être soustrait à ses
obligations depuis 2000 19 mai 2010 neuf
c'était justement dans une stratégie de
retour à une levée des sanctions qui
étouffe qui asphyxient l'économie
iranienne qui en plus est est dans une
situation sanitaire désastreuse tout
cause de pandémie est donc là dessus il
ya un certain de gestes de la part des
états unis qui ont été faits qui sont
des petits gestes mais qui sont des
gestes effectivement qui prouve une
certaine volonté de parvenir à un accord
mais mais sur le fond ça sera
extrêmement difficile et d'autant plus
qu' il ya la perspective effectivement
de l'élection présidentielle iranienne
en juin prochain avec un candidat
potentiellement qu'on le fera
conservateur qui donc la question des
négociations est aussi extrêmement
difficile pour l'actuel gouvernement
iranien qui qui à qui on a imputé
l'échec effectivement de duplicité merci
david rigaud l'hérault d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france je rappelle
que vous êtes chercheur associé à l'iris
et rédacteur en chef revue orient
stratégique merci beaucoup merci